[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
once again happy Wednesday everybody
tonight's monologue is dedicated to all
our friends on the left who are failing
upward leading the chart VP Kamala
Harris it's the only time she's ever LED
and congrats
according to a new poll from NBC which
is like a news network but with Chuck
Todd
combo has the most unpopular VP in
recorded history think about that she
beat out Al Gore
some guy named Biden and even Dick
Cheney and he shot a guy in the face
he had it coming though
I think I really don't know that story
too well anyway so who says women can't
beat men when given the chance yes
ladies you too can suck every bit as
much as men
she truly is the Bud Light of veeps
roll the latest Sven
I'm gonna tell you the Banger of the
summer okay okay that you need to play
for your people and they're gonna love
it everybody's gonna go crazy
[Music]
I like it yes this is the song in the
summer okay so you need to tell the DJ
to have that going okay okay all right
you ready to see Stonewall okay uh oh
that was brutal I haven't heard so much
forced laughter since Kimmel hosted the
Oscars it's more uncomfortable than
Hunter Biden on bring your daughter to
work day
[Laughter]
but even with kamala's approval numbers
in CNN territory she's still a Heartbeat
Away from the presidency and when I say
a heartbeat I'm assuming that Joe still
has one
he isn't even working at half speed
anymore here he is talking about Putin
what extent has Vladimir Putin been
weakened by recently been it's hard to
tell but he's clearly losing the war in
Iraq he's losing the war at home
oh my God we are in some deep trouble
hey Iraq Ukraine tomato tomato let's
just invade both
still the Dems want Kamala right beside
the president perhaps in case he falls
at this point she's less a vice
president and more a Visiting Angel
s
America's Choice
thank you
if only that were true at least then
she'd be useful instead she disappears
for days or weeks only to be found in
Joe's kitchen lacing his ensure with
Prestone
she's like a cicada surfacing
occasionally to make an annoying noise
her staff hates her she really is the
Janice Dean of politicians
who told you I know
it's all the scuttlebutt still her
chances of going from VP to P continued
to rise but isn't this all supposed to
work the other way around aren't we
supposed to be rewarding success and not
failure I mean how about Kareen
Jean-Pierre she just goes to show you
you could be historic and still suck
many things that may be incredibly proud
to be at that Podium during this
historic moment again this is a historic
Administration I'm a historic figure and
I certainly walk in history every day
you're not supposed to tell people
you're historic
other people tell you that you're
historic okay
and you are historic you're the first
press secretary ever to rely solely on
the Fifth Amendment
hahaha
meanwhile as mayor of South Bend Pete
bootage presided over a 75 rise and
crime including record homicides there
would have been even more drive-by
shootings if it weren't for all the
potholes
through the streets had more gaping
wounds than Sonny Corleone at a toll
booth
we've got father fans out there
not many apparently but oh Biden cared
about was that the guy married a dude
and the new job would be his honeymoon
what could go wrong right huh
no wonder the nation's tarmacs are a
mess and no one seems to care and wait
did the teachers union actually Force
our schools to stay closed and your kids
can't read or write a grade level
anymore then why not give Randy
Weingarten a gig with Homeland Security
school safety board
just absolutely no security background
but then again her face alone could
scare off the Wagner group
but you see a trend don't you it's as
plain as the bolts of John fetterman's
neck
I know when the rest of us fail
something admittedly I know very little
about we take our lumps and we walk away
but when the left's chosen ones flunk
and boy do they ever their careers defy
gravity like Jerry nadler's pants
look at that oh that how does that stay
up
Anthony fauci who presided over grants
of U.S tax dollars to the Chinese lab
that almost certainly invented covid
well he'll soon join the staff at
Georgetown as a distinguished professor
of infectious diseases after all who's a
better expert of infectious diseases
than the president of its fan club
and what do former New York Mayor Bill
de Blasio and former Chicago mayor Lori
Lightfoot have in common you know other
than making up one half of The Adams
Family
[Laughter]
that's true
it's all right
we're like two fifths they're both
teaching at Harvard
you know the crime rate in those classes
are going to Skyrocket I hope there's
extra credit for public urination
what about fired sfda chasa Boudin well
he went to Berkeley law disgraced FBI
director James Comey went to Columbia
Law and Hillary Clinton she went to
Columbia's School of public affairs
public affairs
laughs
[Applause]
yeah I'll just say him anyway but it
does sound like a course her husband
should be teaching
I mean you could even lose the L and it
would still work
[Laughter]
lesson one would be the proper use of
cigars
but hey in Hillary's defense I hear
she's the killer behind the podium and
then Jeffrey Epstein's jail cell
oh
what are you booing for look we all know
that Academia is where Lefty failures go
to make future Lefty failures but for
all their education no one taught them
the meaning of meritocracy it's supposed
to be one of America's basic principles
it inspires achievement and Excellence
you rewards success and the nation gets
stronger ignore that and you have a
round robin of cronyism that undermines
quality in our roads our schools our
government our leaders but if America is
going to survive and compete with
Nations that actually send their kids to
school we better stop protecting and
rewarding failures just because they
check a box
but since I'm a glass half full kind of
guy and I am
if we do end up with four more years of
common law at least we always got the
bongos
[Music]
here people of every background I wish
you could see what I'm looking at people
people every background every age
from everywhere
together
[Music]
what's a welcome tonight's guess
he has crumpets and tea and crushes
lefties with Glee Fox News contributor
Douglas Murray
she's a meteorologist and a urologist
because she made Andrew Cuomo wet his
pants but she's senior meteorologist
laugh and the world laughs with you cry
and you're at one of his shows founder
of the loftusparty.com
and finally her husband goes to a
slaughterhouse for some peace and quiet
who's contributor got tip
Douglas always a pleasure to see you I
wish I could say the same
well that was
what do you make of this trend is it
indeed a trend that but basically this
is what happens if you if you make the
number one priority what a person looks
like and not what a person does yeah I
mean internationally there's always this
kind of joke people always joked about
American politicians being lacking in
eloquence should we say there are always
jokes about Dan Quail
um well I mean Reagan even back in the
day Bush you know every Republican and
this was always an international joke
and always kind of uh actually
ill-suited but the Democrats all right
that should be the real joke I mean they
are competing in an eloquence at the
moment I mean every time you see one of
them speaking in front of another one
you think wow they're taking lessons
yeah you remember last year when uh when
Biden welcomed the new Supreme Court
Justice and he said you know you can sum
up America in one word and capital
Harris is standing beside him you can
see in her eyes she's thinking oh no and
he said I think I've got this right he
said I am fatum fatum sorry excuse me
Himalayas yes that's roughly how it came
out that's exactly phonetically correct
and and even Kamala Harris looked like
she thought he hadn't quite got it right
and then and then the other day Biden is
Biden is there when uh when Federman is
is talking and he's looking on and
Federman terms and so it seems really
rather surprised that the president's
beside him and calls the president
collapsed the bridge yes sort of and
even bidened like looking at him
thinking I'm not sure is going so well
so I just I just don't really understand
then you've got the whole Camelot
problem and even without Bongos
I was noticing you know even the Bongos
are starting to wear off on the audience
the bomb goes just to make them laugh
now they just wanted to die
make the Bongos go away I love them I do
too Bongos make everything better
including other Bongos that was the most
interesting I have ever seen Kamala
Harris yes on television yes that didn't
make me cringe and want to like cower in
a corner I mean when she became the vice
president I was kind of rooting for her
a little bit you know glass ceiling
female vice president next in line to
the president it doesn't matter what
party it was it was a moment for women
and then she opens her mouth and it's I
I'm I apologize but I can't it's hard
it's like a Seinfeld episode it's like
it's always about nothing and but she
does it so well like she thinks she's
doing well and the rest of her us are
like
hahaha
she is a giggle machine but she may end
up having the last laugh I mean if
president B croaks she's president and
then we're all screwed by the way did
you get my present I did not I I sent
you some denim bed sheets
I'll have to add them to my collection
I it is here's the thing is it our fault
that it's so easy to make fun of her
because like the thing is it's kind of
like what Jana says you kind of were
rooting for her but she's so bad I was
never rooting for her
and I tell you what it's it's all
theater I feel like as a nation we're
being punked yeah right that somewhere
Ashton Kutcher is just like all right
let's give him Joe Biden and see what
they do now and then with Kamala ding
dong uh the Visiting Angel of Death
who's just waiting like the only upside
is like if something were happened to
Joe and then Kamala would get in we
should all like Embrace her like crazy
so like we're all in on the joke it
would terrify our enemies that's true if
like now granted her speeches are going
to be we're gonna have to White Knuckle
through those yeah those are going to be
a long time yeah it's a great point it
is like a turbulent flight when you're
listening to her speak you're holding on
to the chair you really are like her
State of the Union Address would be like
days okay because like as a nation okay
[Laughter]
and
thank you so much
our only hope is if like we did like a
call and response thing like when you go
to mass and like the the priest says and
be with you and then everybody says it
back yeah if America played along so
every time Kamala would go okay as a
nation we're like okay and that would
terrify our enemies you're starting to
make it sound like it might be fun cat
have you ever been rewarded for failing
doesn't this bother you these people
failing upward we have to achieve in
order to succeed yeah because not only
are they losers but also they're
expensive losers right so there are so
many kids going to school going into
debt to learn from losers and it's just
a horrible model but it's still working
you know universities themselves but I
think I figured out Kamala what I think
I finally figured it out because you
know how we know from all these articles
that are super well sourced well
researched that she's like a tyrant to
work for she's a total jerk so clearly
what she's doing in all these interviews
all these appearances all these speeches
is she is pretending to be happy and
friendly right now that gets confusing
that this is what she thinks a happy
friendly person acts like yeah so I'm
like where was your case study Bonnaroo
yeah because
she seems to be acting like a person who
is artificially happy due to poly
substance drug abuse right
it's such a good point it's like like
the person that always tries to be
everybody loves me is always a monster I
mean that's although everybody says that
about Ainsley
well that's why but that's why you made
the joke about Janice because Janice
like an actually happy nice person right
my husband he joined Twitter for the
first time a few months ago when he was
people are mean on there I don't know if
you guys know that but people say mean
things about me that are horrible
whatever cam comes in he's like
Twitter's awful and I'm like what he's
like people are mean to Janice
like how can you be mean to Janice Dean
I'm like I know there's a song how can
you be mean to Janice Dean I truly can't
imagine it I can I'm thinking it's in my
head right now you can only say that
because you know you really can't
all right hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else